pro wrestler WWE Hall of Famer the Iron
Sheik died last week at age 81 Jesus
Christ he would come on our show and
scream I mean he screamed everywhere he
was a guest on our show eight times did
you know that no I didn't realize it was
that many here's a montage of iron cheek
on our show yelling at various people on
the show [__] you go again I'm gonna
[__]
up you're ready coming you might not
want to [__] him with my dick I wanna
[__] me that beer bottle [__] [__]
I'm a legend before the jabroli my life
with my talent's [__] in your [__]
ass she had an impressive wrestling
background before he started wrestling
in America like he had a legit wrestling
career he represented Iran in wrestling
at the 1968 Olympics and even served as
a bodyguard to the Shah the Shah of Iran
and then he came to the U.S and he was a
villain you know in the wrestling
matches and uh that was around the time
Vince McMahon took over the World
Wrestling Federation he really made Iron
Sheik a big star he even had bad guy
music like it was uh this was the music
he'd walk into the stadium
[Music]
kind of good it's almost like a
Metallica Vibe mixed in with Middle
Eastern influences
beat the American champion Bob backlin
to take the championship in 1983 but
when you take the championship I think
Vince gives it to you right of course a
month after winning the championship
Sheikh wrestled the All-American
up-and-comer Hulk Hogan the hype around
the match helped launch Hulkamania and
contributed to Pro wrestling's growing
popularity three years after the Hulk
Hogan fight she got arrested for drunk
driving and doing drugs with his rival
Hacksaw Jim Duggan
[Laughter]
who would have expected those two to be
together right sheep was let go from the
WWF and only sporadically returned over
the next couple of years the one thing
that continued was Sheikh's drug use it
got so bad
that Sheik would set up tables in
airport hotel lobbies trying to sell
autographs to subsidize his drug habit
he told me about his crack use when he
came on the show in 2007 he was very
honest that makes me very behind better
that give me a lot of power that's me I
never was tired I never missed the show
I never give up and crack is uh highly
addictive but how did you get off of it
did you go to a rehab did you go to some
place for help as a matter of fact
you're very intelligent man
send me to the rehab for one month and
they paid 82 000 and after that I get
sober anyway I mean he is the embodiment
of the American dream he came over from
Iran he was broke he didn't know any
English he worked his ass off and he got
famous
foreign